das gibt es ja nicht doch personen oder
dinge einfach so verschwinden zu lassen
ist ein ganz großer traum der menschheit
ein kanadisches unternehmen hat jetzt
eine spezielle technik entwickelt mit
der nicht nur menschen sondern auch
große objekte wie raumschiffe oder
gebäude unsichtbar gemacht werden können
möglich gemacht werden soll das durch
das so genannte quantum styles material
das für eine bestimmte brechung des
lichts sorgt doch es gibt einen kleinen
haken krieg zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen also erst mal
am anfang die technik funktioniert ja
tatsächlich also im labor zb
funktionieren tarnkappen odertal messe
ja schon unter ganz bestimmten
bedingungen wenn linsen speziell
angeordnet werden oder indem exotische
metamaterialien das licht um ein objekt
leisten sodass es unsichtbar erscheint
und auch das kanadische unternehmen
hyper stelvio technology corporation
macht sich die brechung von licht zu
nutze und es funktioniert die fachleute
wollen eine spezielle technik entwickelt
haben mit der sie nicht nur menschen
sondern auch riesige objekte unsichtbar
machen können in einer pressemitteilung
der firma heißt es es kann eine person
ein fahrzeug ein schiff ein raumschiff
und gebäude versteckt ein stück wand es
kann in jeder umgebung zu jeder
jahreszeit zu jeder tages und nachtzeit
eingesetzt werden wozu keine andere
tarnung in der lage ist weitere vorteile
die gegen die nach unternehmensangaben
darin dass das material nicht nur auch
dünn sondern auch preiswert ist damit
die tarnung funktioniert ist zudem kein
strom notwendig möglich wird das durch
das material mit der bezeichnung quantum
stars diese folie aus kunststoff ist
extrem dünn und bricht das licht so dass
personen und objekte dahinter für den
betrachter vor dem tarnmantel unsichtbar
werden dafür notwendig sind weder
sensoren noch kameras möglich wird das
wohl durch mehrere doppel konvex
geformte linsen die das licht in einem
ganz bestimmten betrachtungswinkel
ablenken so werden die objekte hinter
dieser schicht verborgen damit das
funktioniert muss sich das objekt das
getan werden soll in einem ganz
bestimmten abstand zum material befinden
wenn es zu nah an dem material dran ist
funktioniert die planung nicht und das
objekt oder die person ist
sichtbar doch wie die technik im detail
funktioniert dass es streng geheim
denn die kanadische firma arbeitet schon
seit einigen jahren an dieser technik
des unsichtbar machen das ganze soll dem
kanadischen und us militär zu gute
kommen heißt also spezialeinheiten die
sowieso schon in geheimer mission
unterwegs sind könnten dann quasi
unsichtbar operieren langfristig gesehen
könnte der sogenannte quantum sucht also
der quantum anzug auch dazu führen dass
beispielsweise soldaten unentdeckt
bleiben doch eine herausforderung gibt
es dafür noch zu bewältigen zwar
funktioniert der tarantel im nahen
infraroten licht das sich direkt an
sichtbare spektrum an schließt aber im
richtigen infrarotlicht geht es nicht er
ist nicht in der lage gegen
infrarotstrahlung anzukommen dieses
langweilige licht bricht nämlich in
einem anderen winkel als ultraviolettes
licht oder das sichtbare licht oder eben
das nahe infrarot licht auch
infrarotlicht und das richtige wird vor
allem bei moderner militärausrüstung
eingesetzt unter anderem bei
nachtsichtgeräten
anwendungsmöglichkeiten für die technik
gibt es allerdings auch im zivilen
bereich beispielsweise könnten störende
gebäude oder windräder damit verborgen
werden um das landschaftsbild für deren
betrachter auf dem boden zu verschönern
für flugzeuge in der luft während diese
objekte dann weiterhin sichtbar mal
wieder so eine technik die unsere welt
wirklich komplett verändern kann ich
könnte mir vor allem gebäude zum
beispiel hier in berlin vorstellen die
am besten unter einer solchen folie
versteckt würden
warum existiert eigentlich nicht nichts
dieser frage geht doktor watson in
diesem video nach also anklicken auf
jeden fall anschauen und ihr wisst es
kostenlos ist es ja abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran